She has a lady boner as do I.
Boner city
This is the sexiest thing that's ever happened.
*light jazzy piano*
I told you I was a good dancer. Can I keep you?
I just remember seeing Devin Sawa... and like sweating. And not knowing how to stop it, and feeling really uncomfortable because my mother was next to me.
The music alone is.. *laughing* it's SEX music!
For all the times I've been a genuine jerk this is a real apology.
I didn't realize his voice was like this. I thought it was much deeper.
He's still really hot. He's like 38 I think, but he's like.. I'd still go for it
Like you see these things, and you're not.. It's not clear why they're mesmerizing. *chuckle* Until much later when you see them again and you're like "oh it's soft core porn."
The people of Eternia shall see you kneeling to me.
I'll never kneel to you!
Yes you will!
Oh, oh, this is.. wow... this explains a lot.
I have a diary entree here from like.. 1991 where I'm like seven.
Ok diary I think I'll tell you about Rocky, Rocky and Bullwinkle. My first crush on a cartoon character.
Like the first of many.
Oh well I'm in bed with my pretend friend, Rocky. Wow this is kinda dirty actually.
I just want to be very clear that I am not a furry, but I do remember watching Chip and Dale's Rescue Rangers and seeing the character Gadget and being like...
She's different then other characters isn't she.
What's going on here?
Good morning Gadget!
Oh so Chip and Dale know what's up. So it's not just me that's attracted to Gadget.
There it is. Take off that mask girl. Oh, she's so attractive.
He was so honest, and so... He was a really nice guy.
He's kind of a deadbeat. I think that's the point, which also explains my attraction to deadbeats to this day.
It's just like asking to... stare at people's crouches.
If you have a show for kids that has lots of hot people being really sweaty and aggressive. It's very hard not to be sexually awakened.
I'm still giddy. I'm giddy right now. He's maybe twelve in this movie.
Sorry is it very hot here? I feel like it got extremely hot in here.
*slow sexy jazz*